(applaudissements)
- Dès les premières secondes,
la tension est palpable.
Jean Charest et Pierre Poilievre
sont les deux seuls candidats
à ne pas se serrer la main.
Comme à son habitude,
celui qui est soenent
décrit comme le meneur
dans la course reproche
à l'ancien premier ministre
du Québec d'être un libéral.
Et de mal comprendre la cause
des camionneurs à Ottawa,
qua a a soutenue.
(applaudissements)
Quand Jean Charest réplique et
accuse Pierre Poilievre d'avoir
appuyé des blocages illégaux...
... nombreux dans la foule
huent le candidat québécoi
(huées)
... et signalent clairement
où ils se rangent quand
il est question du convoi.
Le député de la régioOtOtOttawa
maintient la pression sur
son principal adversaire...
... lui demande, avec
insistance, combien d'argent
il a reçu de la compagnie
Huawei, à l'époque de
la détention des deux Michael.
Jean Charest ne répond pas
et tente plutôt de mettre Pierre
Poilievre sur la sellette et
lui reproche de dire une chose
et son contraire sur la loi 21.
La candidate de la droite
sociale, Leslyn Lewis, accus
elle aussi, Pierre Poilievre
de tergiverser, cette fois-ci
sur la question de l'avortement.
Car, plus tôt cette semaine,
en pleine tempête aux États-Unis
heures avant de préciser
qu'il n'allait pas rouvrir
le débat sur la question.
- Let's give a round of ap
to all of our leadership
candidates.
(applaudissements)
- Après une heure et demie
d'échanges acrimonieux, chaque
candidat repart de son côté.
Encore une fois, aucune poignée
de main entre les deux présumés
meneurs. Le fossé qui rerererere
ne pourrait être plus évident.
Ici Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw